One of the best ways to get around Dublin is to ride on this double-decker, the hop-on hop-off.
Let's go.
You've arrived at Dublin City, folks.
Welcome aboard.
Okay, I've just gotten off the bus.
I'm here on Grafton Street.
There are shops everywhere, live music on every block.
It's a lot of fun.
You're pretty tall for a leprechaun.
I thought you're supposed to be short.
Probably Ireland's first great rock superstar.
Alright, here we go, getting off the bus,...
...seeing some other exciting spots.
Okay, we're at St. Stephen's Green.
We're right here in the very epicenter of the park.
Just behind us here is the ornamental duck pond.
It's very popular in the summer months with Spanish students feeding the ducks in the pond.
I'm here in Ireland at the Guinness factory.
Time to try it out.
Guinness!
I'm at Trinity College which is one of the best universities in the entire world.
And it's also home to the Book of Kells.
Wow, what a fun day!
But you know all this bus riding is making me tired.
I think it's time, time to find a pub.